generally the brain activity is too late
so without backward time referral you
don't have even the possibility for
real-time conscious action and
Consciousness would therefore be epi
phenomenal and we have a false illusion
which most people think are the party
line in neuroscience and philosophy
starting from Dan Dennett and uh Dan
Wagner's book The Illusion of free will
is that free will is an illusion because
the activity happens too late and our
non-conscious autopilot acts first
although they never explain where the
brain activity is for the non-conscious
autopilot because that should have some
activity too and then we have this false
illusion after the fact that we were in
control Consciousness and illusion the
backward time effect rescues
subconscious free will